there are layers upon layers to explore
in the ending of cocaine bear or other
let's find out what's going on between
the lines when sarri finally finds DD at
the end of cocaine bear she's taking
shelter in the Bear's own cave
presumably the bear took her there
although the logistics of the whole
thing are kind of brushed over it takes
Sally and Henry all day to track DD down
so she must have gotten to the cave
pretty fast after the initial attack
then there are even more questions like
why the bear didn't eat her first not to
overthink it anyways Sally and Henry's
arrival at the bear Lair brings a not so
shocking Revelation the bear itself
revealed earlier to be female has two
curbs and yes they also got into that
nasty powder according to Smithsonian
Magazine mother bears have been known to
use humans as protection for their
offspring though not quite enough kidnap
you and take you to live in my cave kind
of way but with her brain chemistry
being effectively Rewritten by the dope
maybe the cocaine bear was hoping for
Dede to act as a kind of Guardian a
common idea that Mama bears up into
defend that Cubs from humans
aggressively is widely disputed however
the cocaine bear doesn't seem to be
protective as much as she is manic and
hurt alas these violent Delights have
violent ends and the ending of cocaine
bear is nothing if not Shakespearean
before sarri can get DeDe and Henry out
of the cocaine bears cave sit in his
crew show up they find a good amount of
dope stashed under the Cub's noses but
Sid isn't satisfied he reminds Eddie of
his earlier threats that the cards held
from which he gets his shipments will
come for them both and for Eddie's own
son if they don't reclaim the drugs more
this may be true no one else in the gang
seems gung-ho to continue the hunt
crooked officer Reba decides she's had
it with the whole ordeal and declares
her intention to leave when Sid pulls a
gun on her David steps in the way it's a
pretty surprising move given how much
David has been willing to give up his
fingers for instance in pursuit of the
cocaine but even he says most loyal
follower seems to have hit his limit
this is a kind of deeply human question
that cocaine bear was clearly conceived
to explore what is the breaking point of
someone who's dedicated themselves to a
life of crime when is enough enough for
David it comes in the middle of the bear
cave his literal darkest moments in the
movie
the titular Behemoth isn't the only Mama
to be reckoned with in cocaine bear
sorry proves to be quite the force of
nature herself and push comes to shove
willing to do anything to defend her own
curves when Sid confronts her DeDe and
Henry as are escaping the cave she shows
no sign of fear even when he starts
waving his gun around it doesn't shake
her when she finesses that same gun into
her own hands her unwavering bravery
becomes even more apparent wanting
nothing more than to be rid of the
cocaine the bear and the assembled gang
of crooks for good sorry leaps off a
perch with the kids in tow into the
Rushing Water beneath the waterfall lo
and behold mama bear gets that Cubs out
safe it's a triumphant moment there is
no greater power cocaine bear seems to
say that of a mother fighting for her
children in a way cocaine bear acts as
its own PSA in the style of the old
anti-drug commercials Montage at its
start the lesson seems to be don't
become a cocaine Kingpin because if you
do a 400 pound black bear will rip out
your own trails and feed them to her
babies
cocaine are very very bad
clearly Sid didn't get that memo when
everyone else including his own son
insists of the adventure is foolhardy
Sid remains dedicated even without his
gun he refuses to abandon the course so
Eddie and David leave him for a moment
it looks like the villain who represents
the evil machinations of the underworld
at large might win but then cocaine bear
tears open Sid's guts and her Cubs Feast
this scene is particularly wild given
that cocaine bear was the last movie Ray
Liotta filmed before his death but
according to director Elizabeth Banks he
was a huge fan of his absurd role bangs
said at the film's premiere he came in
for ADR eight days before he passed away
actually and he loved it he was so happy
he was laughing it was just delightful
leota's absurd Turner Sid is a memorable
one worthy of the late star's impressive
body of work the original true story
that inspired cocaine bear didn't
exactly have a happy ending for the bear
though it was certainly preferable for
the humans involved the story only
emerged after the Bear's dead body was
discovered in the woods next to to a
good portion of the discarded dope there
was no Rampage no cinematic bloodbath
just a poor innocent animal whose body
gave vowels after ingesting an ungodly
amount of the stuff cocaine bear gives
its titular character a more optimistic
ending despite absorbing a similarly
massive quantity of Colombian white the
mama bear in her Cubs all seem fine at
the end of the movie given the sad story
of the actual cocaine bear dubbed Pablo
Escobar after its death it's nice to see
the movie version go out on a happier
note in an interview with Entertainment
Weekly prior to the release of the film
Elizabeth Banks said she saw her version
as a Revenge story for the bear koki we
call the bear Cokey on-screen takes to
the end of cocaine bear says a good
portion of the dumb drugs wind up
unaccounted for it's difficult to
pinpoint how accurate that is to the
true story but in the movie viewers see
at least one full duffel bag escaping
the hands of stash one third of the
misguided knife gang known as satoshamps
sash is the only one to survive the film
What Becomes of sash is difficult to say
but that's part of
that makes cocaine Bears so complex
regardless it's a good thing he keeps
the powder out to the mouths of the
sheep and the truck he catches a ride in
cocaine's sheep just doesn't have the
same ring to it
I don't have to listen to this what's
his cocaine bear really about like the
epic poetry that is the Fast and Furious
franchise it's a story about family but
specifically the relationships between
parents and their children nearly every
chord character has some kind of
parent-child relationship that ties them
to this central theme there's obviously
the bear herself who fights to protect
her Cubs and sarri who Ventures into
danger to ensure her daughter's safety
when said the Manson know who sorry is
during the climax she responds simply a
mom in the moments it's all that matters
in the same scene Henry gives it a piece
of his own mind saying you're a piece of
crap person and a bad dad in the latter
somatic framework of the film the second
indictment is even more Curtin than the
first Sid is a bad dad rather than
console Eddie after the loss of his love
Joan he prods and tricks him into
rejoining the Crooked family business
one that Eddie now despises I I don't
like this please stop to be fair Eddie
has been lacking in the parental
department but he steps back into his
duty tease as a father with a puppy in
tow and possibly on Blow at the end of
the story with David by his side and the
near-death experience behind him it
seems like he's on the right path it's
also nice to see a happy ending for
rosette the dog who functionally serves
as a child figure for detective Bob the
veteran cop may die and ceremoniously
atop a gazebo but his last thoughts are
of rosettes this sweet moment connects
Bob to the greater thematic tapestry of
cocaine bear reaffirming the film's
literary merit another major theme
running through the bloodstream of
cocaine bear is the utter incompetence
of American institutions Elizabeth Banks
has spoken about cocaine bear being
about America's failed War on Drugs and
there's clear satire in the film's take
on both law enforcement and the
narcotics trade early almond sari joins
up with park ranger Liz she seems
surprised that the other woman has a gun
as Liz responds Park ranges are peace
officers that means we can shoot people
the Paradox of her reply he's just one
of the film's Jabs at the law
enforcement establishment portrayed
throughout his bumbling and ineffectual
later on while trying to kill the bear
Liz shoots one of the deschamps in the
back of the head this takedown of
Institutions extends to the drug
business itself the fact that Andrew
Thornton who was a Narcotics officer for
the government before jumping the fence
and becoming a Smuggler by the way dies
jumping out of his airplane it's just
ridiculous but then that's one of the
parts of the movie that's completely
true to fact Sid ends up getting eaten
under a waterfall in the middle of
nowhere all because of people he works
with are rotten at their jobs if there's
a final resounding message that cocaine
bear seems to endorse is that no matter
how much humans subdue and Ben nature it
will never be fully conquered at the end
of the movie that's certainly true
supposed Wildlife experts and animal
rights activist Peter acts as a kind of
incompetent wall against which the film
spatters The Brute Force of nature he
calls animals friends because he doesn't
like to call them animals and he's
incense when he learns that someone must
have set the bear off somehow did you
feed a cocaine Peter clearly has good
intentions but his view of the natural
world is a child that must be protected
is ill-equipped to deal with reality
humans do ravage their natural
environment daily it's equally true that
nature bites back be it diseases natural
disasters or bears
cocaine Bears a rare exception in
today's Blockbuster landscape an
exciting unique film based on the
pre-existing IP and with no apparent
intention of spawning sequels but this
is 2023 and a movie is only as valuable
as the Studio's ability to turn it into
a franchise while the bear itself is
alive and well at the end of the movie a
sequel hardly seems like it would have
much story to stand on now sequel plans
have been announced that again before
the film was even released to theaters
soon to be viewers took to the internet
to discuss the possibility of a
so-called cocaine shark after several
tons of the drug were found floating off
the coast of New Zealand somewhere
somebody is undoubtedly optioning the
rights even Elizabeth Banks had a
response from people asked her about it
saying I've seen that if there's a great
story then sure jaws with cocaine I
don't see how that loses branching out
into the rest of the animal kingdom for
more movies like cocaine Bears sounds
like the smarter move should Universal
decide to go that route the
possibilities are endless cocaine rests
gotten quite mad as trying to escape up
in this cage here
however cocaine bear would likely be
remembered best for what it is right now
A one-off goof spoof of a wild true
story about the War on Drugs Parenthood
and a massive bear on cocaine
[Music]